[Music]
you're practical and you've always been
that way cheap I wouldn't say cheap I
say practical you also seem like a very
like a strong person and I don't just
mean like you're you're emotionally
strong spiritually strong but you you
claim that you can take care of yourself
well I mean I don't want to be put to
the test for everybody watching but I
could throw a punch yes right I know how
to like when I was 10 maybe 11 I did a
show called Walker Texas Ranger yeah a
little known after Chuck Norris Wow okay
alright that Chuck took it upon himself
to teach me how to kick him for a punch
wait so you were ten and chuck was
telling you here's how you throw a punch
yeah it was like in between takes he
talked to me about going to Moscow and I
was like oh yeah I've been there and
then he was like let me show you how to
throw a punch and I was like okay like
that was literally what happened and
when I shot the episode by the end of it
I was like I know I did throw a punch to
you - Chuck nice that's pretty cool I
know it's a pretty cool story right have
you ever have you ever mean it's not
like you're ever gonna really throw up
no no I don't actually when I hit a
person yeah like I can fake it in a
movie yeah yeah also when you're in
labor you might that's just I'm just
telling you it could happen
you